eu vim de bodocó exu bodocó é uma típica
cidade do interior
pernambuco a região de onde eu vim
era muito quente e seca
as pessoas têm dificuldade de conviver
com a estiagem porque tudo em função
dela
as pessoas precisam ser forte as pessoas
precisam ser muito resistente para viver
naquela região
eu acho até que resistir é o destino de
quem vive no sertão
o curioso é que essa região apesar de
ser muito quente e seca ela também é
muito fértil
qualquer chuvinha que é suficiente para
mudar o ambiente
a paisagem que antes era ocre marrom
verdinha e fica um cheiro de mato
a mesma coisa que acontece na vida das
pessoas que enfrentam numerosas
dificuldades é um ovo e mesmo assim
quando aparece qualquer oportunidade às
pessoas que pegam esse momento e se
transforma as pessoas florescem
eu tenho um amigo que ele diz que o
sertão a experiência tão forte que a
gente sai do sertão mas o sertão não sai
da gente
quando eu saí do sertão eu era
adolescente eu que não tem nada queria
ganhar o mundo e vêm para a região que é
exatamente o contrário daquela região
que tem muita água tenham mar que os
rios e eu vim justamente para remar
contra a corrente
no recife a capital de pernambuco
eu cheguei aos 15 anos e foi aos 15 anos
que eu vi o mar pela primeira vez e uma
era muito mais do que podia suportar as
minhas fantasias
o recife é a cidade dos meus sonhos
o recife é a cidade das possibilidades
era tudo acontecia
e como diz a pressão popular
eu vim
sem dinheiro no banco e sem parentes
importantes mas eu também não estava a
fim de fazer aquela linha sem
sobreviventes da seca
não eu vim a preocupar o meu espaço
todo mundo tem as suas verdades
eu estava em busca da minha eu vim para
estudar e vinho sobretudo para mim
presentifica identificar a minha
realidade é instaurar a minha realidade
é quem mudou para a capital foi meu pai
ele queria que eu estudasse para ser
médico ele queria ter um filho que foi
chamado de doutor porque ela no interior
toda a família é tão filho doutor e eu
não queria ser doutor
tudo que eu queria era ser jornalista
eu sempre quis ser jornalista desde que
eu me lembro era moleque e já queria ser
jornalista
e aí é entre eu e meu pai teve uma
divergência que durou meses
mas aí depois ele compreendeu e me
apoiou porque ele entendeu que quando a
gente deseja muita coisa a gente
encontra forças na alma é o estudante de
pernambuco é uma república de estudantes
que naquela época abrigava cerca de 600
estudantes cerca de 600 então assim
aquilo ali foi uma época de muito
aprendizado eu aprender principalmente a
compartilhar compartilhar sonhos
compartilhados teza compartilha
frustrações compartilhar alegrias
algumas conquistas e aí eu descobri
também ali que compartilhar é só resiste
quem compartilha é importante a tal
ponto que só existe quem compartilha do
estudante foi esperto e faculdade da
universidade da vida pra mim porque eram
pessoas pensam diferente em cada pessoa
tenha uma maneira de ver a vida
mas a gente tem o mesmo objetivo está
ali que é
estudar e têm uma disciplina quer
aprender a viver com a gente não tinha
muita alternativa como as coisas eram
muito difíceis
eu entrei entrei de cabeça na os estudos
e também na leitura
a leitura pra mim naquela época lhe
muito
lia bastante eu li tudo o que encontrava
na frente porque a leitura pra mim era
como se fosse uma busca por respostas
era uma busca de sentidos
eu queria ler para saber o que é que
estava sendo o que estava representando
eu já estava naquele processo
existencial
eu estava querendo me engajar na vida
e aí eu lia interpretável tentava
ressignificar o que eu estava vivendo a
leitura ela me permitiu ser uma pessoa
que melhor uma pessoa que cresceu uma
pessoa que entendia melhor a vida
entender melhor a volta das pessoas
entende melhor a mim mesmo eu me tornei
mais tolerante
eu acho que eu me tornei a pessoa que eu
sempre desejei que se através da leitura
me conduzir pela leitura que eu fui ler
diretamente no livro no mundo porque o
mundo é muito cheio de imagem no mundo é
muito cheio de informação e é preciso
que a gente saiba lei e eu logo aprendi
que eu nunca tenha recebido nada de mãos
beijadas
mas eu também não estava a fim de abrir
mão de nada que eu desejava
foi assim com dificuldades dificuldades
financeiras e também lendo bastante que
eu fiquei cinco anos na casa do
estudante e terminei a faculdade de
jornalismo e quando depois voltar minha
faculdade de jornalismo não foi assim na
região dois empregos mas o primeiro
emprego
foi dificílimo eu tive que ralar muito
para conseguir emprego e quando consegui
o emprego foi para ser repórter da área
policial
todo mundo queria ser repórter de
política repórter de economia repórter
de cultura porque aquele era chique
foi repórter policial ficava reservado
há assim uma espécie de quarta categoria
de jornalista mas é o que me restava eu
fui que estejam na lista policial
o dia a dia de um repórter policial é de
de convivência com as grandes tragédias
humanas
você começa a ter um dia a dia muito
doloroso muito sangrento com histórias
muito dramáticas e eu comecei a conviver
temos passou-se um momento engraçado
comigo porque eu comecei a conviver com
essa realidade e com a minha tela
dificuldades ainda eu comecei a viver
uma espécie de hiper realidade eu
comecei a ter necessidade de incorporar
ficção na minha vida
e foi aí que eu descobri a literatura
não agora mas como leitura mas como
necessidade de expressão eu queria agora
escrever
foi aí que eu comecei a querer ser
escritor
até porque o repórter de polícia ele
começa também até contatos com as tramas
são fantásticas que nem um ficcionista
podem supor a vida é muito maior do que
qualquer ficção você começa a ter umas
histórias que são muito loucas e você
começa a descobrir também personagens
tão complexos que você vai querer
escrever sobre ele você vai querer dar
voz a esses personagens e eu estava ali
e já que eu estava ali eu seria o
narrador daquelas histórias daqueles
personagens é e aí eu percebi que a
gente narra também para resistir a gente
narra para escrever a nossa história
aqui e para mandar recados para o futuro
a gente narra pra poder a gente ser
resistir às invasões existir as pessoas
que estão querendo nos impor alguma
coisa
a palavra terminou sendo reestruturada
dor da minha vida
e aí eu percebi também que eu se eu tava
agora como narrador escrevendo mais
bacana eu agora queria histórias boas
também para contar e eu saí como
repórter em busca de matérias diferentes
entrem em contato
com um grupo de garotos de rua foi
difícil primeiro contato mas aí depois
eu terminei conquistando a amizade deles
e aí naquele momento eu descobri que tem
muitas meninas no grupo
só que aí nas conversas e fui percebendo
que na verdade aquelas meninas do grupo
nem todas elas eram meninas eram meninos
eles se vestiam de menino alguns porque
tava a fim de se vestir como menino
menina e outros que estavam a fim de que
queriam apenas bem a vida porque assim
se estende mineiros podiam se prostituir
e podiam sobreviver bem há dinheiro para
comer para viver para fazer as coisas
mais simples do dia a dia
a matéria foi causou um impacto foi uma
espécie de de tapa na cara de um
sociedade que acha que protege sua
infância mas não protege e eu ganhei o
meu primeiro prêmio na área de direitos
humanos e de proteção à cidadania
uma coisa mais ou menos assim eu fui
investigar depois porque pernambuco era
um estado que mais produzir maconha no
país
eu fui para uma região que era chamada o
polígono da maconha que ficava às
margens do rio são francisco no sertão
foi uma matéria difícil perigosa
evidentemente mas eu cheguei lá
conversei com as pessoas é entrar em
contato com as pessoas que estavam
cantando e voltei pra redação com uma
série de reportagens uma dessas matérias
mostravam que aquelas pessoas que
estavam plantando já tenha plantado
culturas tradicionais antes implantado
cebola tem implantado feijão tenham
implantado frutas
mas acontece que elas não recebiam
incentivos do governo do governo federal
elas não tinham sequer como escoar a
produção delas fica vendo ali naquela
feira das cidades vizinhas e o que
apurava mal dava pra pagar suas contas e
com a maconha nos tinham retorno
imediato praticamente então por isso
elas optaram tantar maconha
a matéria também foi bastante polêmica e
eu recebi também um prêmio
ganhamos prêmios e mudando ocupando
novas posições que eu cheguei de do
executivo de um grande jornal
fiquei nesse jornal como editor
executivo durante alguns anos até que eu
publiquei uma matéria que faziam grave
denúncia social
a matéria dizia que existe uma fazenda
com 1.200 homens vivendo em regime de
semi-escravidão publica matéria o
governo federal foi lá a conquista
confirmou os dados confirmam inclusive
um número que a matéria publicada e
esses homens puderam finalmente retornar
para suas casas
voltar para suas vidas dignas eu acho
que o fato de ter voltado para a vida
digna dele sempre foi o maior prêmio que
recebi na minha carreira como jornalista
porém foi ele voltando pra casa deles e
eu voltando para minha com a minha
carteira de trabalho na mão porque a
empresa jornal não interessou aquele
tipo de denúncia eu fui ao conteúdo fiz
o contrário que estavam querendo
então fui demitido
as portas do jornalismo pernambucano se
fecharam para mim e eu fiquei vivendo
por muito tempo muitos anos como
freelancer teve que readequar a minha
vida eu tive que reajustar muita coisa
não foi fácil não foi bem difícil mas o
fato de eu ter saído do do jornal não
significou para mim o fim da minha
carreira como jornalista eu continuo
analista mas também o como eu trabalhava
cerca de 10 horas por dia às vezes até
mais
agora eu podia me dedicar um pouco mais
à literatura
e aí eu comecei a escrever muito mais
engraçada que eu levei para a literatura
coisas que eu tenho aprendido no
jornalismo a fazer para escrever eu
conversava com as pessoas ele avistava
pessoas eu pesquisava eu também é
repórter de jornal para tirar dali
personagens e tramas escrevia procurava
palavras mais simples escrever a frase
mais curta e não evitava muito a
pontuação dessa
como evitar que o leitor deve voltar diz
no texto que o texto fosse mais fluídico
misturei realidade com ficção
então eu terminei a desenvolver um
estilo próprio mais ou menos porque eu
estava desenvolvendo a partida dessa
mistura de linguagens do jornalismo e da
literatura
e foi assim é que eu eu lancei três
romances premiados frança e dois livros
de contos premiados
lancei ué biografias das peças de teatro
que eu tenho escrito cinco delas já
foram montadas é mas apesar dessa
produção eu nunca tive acesso às grandes
editoras no país
mandei textos procurei as pessoas mandar
originais mas nunca recebi sequer
respostas
aí é o procurei um grupo de amigos que
também eram escritores e que esse grupo
já existia eu procurei esse grupo que
passava pela mesma situação ea gente
formou um grupo chamado autoajuda
literária
esse grupo é formado por mim cleyton
cabral que está aqui presente
raimundo de moraes jerusalém e ao luz e
muda chama se auto ajuda literária o
nome desse grupo é meio irônico porque é
não tem uma cor de auto ajuda mas ele
procura nos fortalecer
ele procura haver uma troca maior das
nossas coisas ele procura dar mais
visibilidade a gente esse grupo nos
fortalece e enfim é muito bacana a gente
se reúne a cada 15 dias faz oficinas a
gente discutir livros que a gente lê que
a gente discutia ventos
agora nós também é como já tinha dito
antes é a gente se juntando a gente
compartilhando a gente se fortalece
foi o que aconteceu com esse grupo por
quem deu visibilidade ea gente não tem
mais aquela aquela ilusão de que vai
ganhar dinheiro com literatura e também
a gente sabe que é não vai ficar no
famoso ou literatura mas a gente quer
evitar nossos livros a gente quer que
chegue nas mãos
olimpo foi dessa suspensão dessa forma
que nós criamos o selo gene edison gene
gene porque a homenagem à personagem
chico buarque de holanda que se chama
gene que é uma periférica que é uma
pessoa discriminada que uma pessoa é
marginalizada e nós de certa forma somos
mesmo um pouco para o inferno da
política das grandes editoras
então é na travessa dessa dessa é de
selo
nós lançamos dois livros mundo um dos
quais sugestões para escritores a é
novos e que foi porque tão a fim de
escrever e na no lançamento que é
bastante gente nova e aquilo nos deu uma
troca legal
então eu acho que se você é um escritor
novo ou uma pessoa que escreve mas não
consegue publicar não fique esperando
pelas grandes editoras
é de você mesmo seu livro as grandes
editoras elas podem ter a política dela
de indiferença mas você não tem que
esperar por elas
você não é obrigado a nada você só é
obrigado a ter compromisso com a sua
literatura eu por exemplo resolveu não
esperar não tem com esse grupo até
porque minha história de vida sempre foi
essa a sair do interior foi morar em
casa do estudante de jornalismo que foi
o contrário do que uma parte queria
conseguir um bom emprego foi demitido
por causa de uma matéria que contrariava
os interesses do jornal mas eu nunca
traí os meus princípios eu nunca traí
meus sonhos
se você é jornalista
se você é escritor se você advogado se
você é médico ou qualquer que seja sua a
sua atuação não entregue os seus sonhos
nas mãos de terceiros
sabe por quê por que o sonho é feito de
uma matéria muito dele tá bem rara
o sonho ele é feito com a mesma matéria
da vida da gente ea vida está passando
rápido demais
mais um minuto ea porta do futuro já se
abre e esse minuto aqui quando ele
passar a ele
operavam no futuro quando isso aqui tudo
foi passado
você vai se sentir você vai ser lembrado
ou lembrada não é pela quantidade de
dinheiro que você juntou no metrô fama
que você conseguiu não você vai ser
lembrado ou lembrada é pela sua
capacidade de ter comovido às pessoas
com seu sonho é pela sua competência de
ter movido o seu sonho para a vida real
transformado a sua vida ea vida das
pessoas a partir dos seus sonhos
a vida é de quem sonha gente ou é dessa
forma ou você não vai deixar vestígios
da sua passagem dessa nave e até gente
eu acho que a gente tem que se apropriar
do sonho a gente tem que se apropriar e
esse personagem principal da nossa vida
sabe a gente tem que escrever a nossa
história
a gente tem que ser protagonista dessa
história então já que a gente tem que
escrever essa história comece agora a
escrever essa história
obrigado a todos os gêneros aqui
presente